newsom
says california will pay off unpaid rent
occurred
accrued during coronavirus pandemic fox
news story california pulled off all the
past due
rent accumulated by residents during the
coronavirus pandemic the move would
fulfill a promise to help landlords
break even while giving renters a clean
slate
according to reports this week the state
has about 5.2 billion
from federal aid packages approved by
congress to pay out people's rents
which could be enough to cover said
jason elliott senior counselor
to newsome on housing homelessness
what's unclear is whether california
will continue to ban evictions for
unpaid rent beyond june 30th the date
california's evictions
moratorium is set to expire nationally
actually it looks like the biden
administration is going to push it to
july the 31st because our
nationally national which means they're
going to probably extend as well yes
okay so um and why are they extending it
because
our bureaucrats that spend all this
money on their credit card get that
credit card away from them
they couldn't distribute the 47 billion
dollars in rent relief
quickly enough so they need another
month to get the money to the people
these are our bureaucrats so any chance
you're moving to california
hell no but wait wait wait hi wasn't
there a recall
it wasn't california google knew some
recall
whoa that went down this chair
to face recall well yeah we're we had
major williams on here we know what's
going on
when is that in november no this is
yesterday
this is this is governor newsome will
face recollection just making a second
time in state history that special
election will be held recall state
governor state officials confirm
wednesday that a recall election will
proceed
after just 43 people withdrew their
signatures from petitions to recall
only 43 during the 30-day window
required by state laws the result
california department
of finance will now begin estimating the
cost of recall including cost of holding
as it as a special election as part of
its next regular regularly
scheduled election which will then be
submitted to the governor the lieutenant
governor secretary of state and the
chairperson of the
joined legislative budget committee by
august according to a letter outlining
the process okay wow interesting the
financial representation
the recall will cost 215.2
million dollars a day that has not yet
been set huh
but this is actually happening this is
what happens in states that close
outdoor
dining this is what happens but he has
to be able to go to french laundry
though he's got to be able to go to the
restaurant you can't stop him from going
there
yeah so bring it back to this uh and
that's a fact
unpaid rent so that's a fact all these
people conspiracy theories that's a fact
so all these people are essentially who
have not been paying rent they have not
the opportunity to work their business
has been closed
small businesses have been closed 40 40
of us landlords are small businesses
they're not all big companies
48 of landlords mom and pop i
own a few rental properties they're not
blackstone they're not blackrock
it's my retirement income blah blah blah
and they've been just so they haven't
been paying their rent for a year
they're off the hook free lunch all
these renters and then the government's
going to reimburse
these small businesses the landlords
well i mean all the landlords so some of
them
will be big yeah don't go don't don't
push the blackstone button those ugh
so who's the big winner in this the
people that just got free rent for the
last year and a half
of course they're the big winner yeah i
mean stories are proliferating about
people gaming the system
huge surprises we're getting free rent
the non-workers the the people that are
now
maybe they were working maybe they were
not working i don't know that's not how
this thing works
okay there's a little bit of math here
right 300 a week in supplemental
unemployment benefits right yeah so
supplemental that's that's on top of
what your state was giving you yeah
yes so but 1200 a month give or take the
average rent in america is
1600. so your stimulus your benefit from
the government
was way bigger than what you were
getting for sitting on your ass and not
working
way bigger think about that say those
numbers again your stimulus was big
average rent nationwide sixteen hundred
dollars that extra three hundred dollars
a week twelve hundred dollars the rental
thing was a bigger stimulus package
do you understand yeah 100 because your
rent is 1600.
so the other one is 1200 so 1600 you're
not paying the rent so you've got
another times 18 months
essentially it wasn't one time exactly
2800 bucks
right every month and by the way the
lifts are coming quicker
because the gig workers are pouring back
into let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question you said who who pay
the price
let me take a different angle on this
and and i want to hear your thoughts on
this so check this out
so during bad times desperation
okay when a person is desperate you got
two different types of people
the guy that's a worker who's always
wanting to work and improve
is he going to work during bad times
let me ask a question one more time hear
me out kai adam pay attention to what
i'm saying hear me out what i'm saying
during great good times during bad times
good times great times
the guy that's constantly a worker a
hustler creative
innovative wants to constantly improve
whatever his situation is
does he do that during bad times yes
does he do it during good times
yes does he do it during great times now
watch this the guy that's always
trying to find a way a shortcut to avoid
work
doesn't want to watch if you give him
the easy way out he's always going to
take it
does he work during bad times he'll know
no he'll take this does he
work during good times maybe does he
work during great times
it's all one big question the point is
if you allow
him to not work and take a shortcut to
kick back he will always take it and if
you allow
the worker the innovative the creative
guy to work he will always take that
option what percentage of america
which is why during the pandemic the
rich got
so much richer and the poor got poorer
very simple not because of the shutdown
or any of that stuff
it's because during covet when we did a
i did a video a year ago i said let me
let me put it to you this is what's
going to happen right now
there's going to be those during covet
that are going to get destroyed and it's
the majority
they're going to get destroyed okay
because they're going to be like oh it's
not
my fault oh i can't believe what
happened oh i can't believe this then
there's going to be the people in the
middle that nothing changes which means
they stay the same they just survived
they're like i'm a survivor i'm a
survivor it's just surviving for the
rest of their life
all they do is as long as they survive
they're good then there's the there's a
go
there's a folks that are going to be
like dude are you flipping kidding me
i'm going to go light it up right now
and they did
not a little bit a lot of it look what
happened microsoft is officially 2
trillion
company now right a lot of wealth was
made the last 12 months so when you ask
the question who paid the price
who won here and we say oh the people
that got the the stimulus and the rent
and all that stuff they didn't win they
lost because their habits just
officially got even
worse and it's officially in the next 12
months their habits are going to be
what is that one thing you put that
magnify magnified it's going to be
magnified in ways that we've never seen
we will see we we we're up to
unfortunately
we're back up to 580 000 um homeless in
america
it's it's a tragedy it's it's been
rising since 2017.
so we're going to see homelessness rise
and we're going to see
people who lose everything who don't
want to work
get really mad so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye